press preview first look at what is on
tomorrow's front pages and tonight we'll
check out the headlines with the
columnist
carol malone and the editor of
birmingham live and the birmingham
male graham brown so let's take a look
first of all at some of the front pages
for you the eye reports there are plans
to offer
people a third kovid-19 jab starting in
october
to boost immunity as the uk heads
towards the winter months
here's the front of the metro leading
with the french president emmanuel
macron blaming the eu
for problems with the vaccine rollouts
on the continent
the ft says the indian government is
refusing to
export any more of its kovid vaccine
stocks despite
being the world's biggest manufacturer
of doses up to now because the country
is facing a new
outbreak of its own fury
over covid pub passport on phones is the
headline leading the daily mail
suggesting plans for a mobile app which
will prove someone's had a jab
negative test or is immune
now the guardian takes the angle that
the public passports are being proposed
in an effort to increase the number of
younger people
wanting to be vaccinated
the daily mirror writes that families of
loved ones have covered victims are
demanding boris johnson set a date for
an inquiry into the mishandling of the
crisis
with the headline tell us why they died
according to the telegraph the education
secretary gavin williamson has
denounced threats sent to a teacher in
yorkshire who was suspended
for showing pupils cartoons of the
prophet muhammed
and graham's paper the birmingham mail
tells the story of 10 year old
isaac whose family were forced into a
mile daily round trip to bring him to
school after the city's social housing
authorities
relocated them to a hotel in manchester
still waiting for carol to join us but
graham brown
is here good to see you graeme thanks
for joining us hopefully carol will
check in in a few moments but let's get
cracking shall we
looking first of all at the front of the
metro i mean most of the papers
all going with the the vaccine crisis
the issue
with supplies throughout europe
and uh the metro macro eu is to
blame uh he's saying that france and the
rest of the eu didn't go fast enough
or strong enough on vaccines
yeah i was a reminder but it's
fascinating what's up what's happening
with the eu
and and this is just sort of the latest
you know we've had what's already been
an embarrassing miracle
from but for emmanuel macron coming out
and all of these and all the things he
said about astrazeneca in the first
place
today he said they were wrong to lack
ambition i can only imagine the extent
to which that was said
to er through gritty then um
he's clearly not keen to give the uk a
lot of credit for what's happening uh
here at the moment um elsewhere we've
had uh that we've heard from austria
that they're not very happy with the
amount of jobs they're getting that that
uh that they think is gonna have a knock
on effect to what it's gonna mean for
the eu in a long time
angela merkley was seamlessly seemingly
sort of imperious before
she's having to she's at a u-turn um on
an easter lockdown in in germany
jean-claude jung has come out today
worrying about what it means for the
for the future of the of the eu it is
interesting in that yeah it seems so
imperious throughout the
brexit negotiations um but but it seemed
different now i mean even
you know we've had we've had this eu and
uk joint statement sort of saying that
we're going to work together but i'm
even today
matt hancock sort of chipping away at
the eu and and talking about
that they uh that they think it's gonna
that we've gotta we've got a better deal
i think
i think what's really interesting about
this is that yeah we're seeing the the
european union being painted as this
sort of nasty goliath of an operation
which
seems like it seems talking about face
really as compared to what uh what we
saw throughout the the brexit
negotiation where it might have been
seen as
anti-democratic but largely sort of
bumbling really and and
uh but yeah he was making an argument
about being sort of inclusive but now
we're seeing they're talking about
holding back vaccines
um yeah you're seeing a different like i
mean the truth is this is what the eu's
about the eu is about power it's about
being a huge trading block and in a
world of superpowers
about having about having that power but
you just see it in a new light really
that's really interesting you know they
are
i'm not sure they like seeing the uk
doing something better and more we made
a hall exactly of uh
out of corona certainly making a great
job out of the vaccine roll
out yeah and uh just reading today that
uh in poland fewer than half
of people there have turned up for the
astrozenica jab
uh 61 of uh french people are saying
it's unsafe as well as the politics
there's a real issue in persuading
many europeans to take the jab in the
first place
yeah and i mean i am the editor of the
very mail and and um
and we've had that we've had our issues
similarly here you know that we
we had a time where there were wards of
birmingham where more than 50 percent of
people weren't uh weren't signing up i
can tell you today
the first day months and months and
months that we've reported
that there's no deaths whatsoever in in
in a 24-hour period in birmingham and
i'd personally like to thank astrazeneca
for that i kind of get a feeling you
know that they're
sort of wondering why they bothered at
the moment yet certainly
we're now seeing that uh that across
europe and i mean
again you come back to the kind of
gritty two through which emanuel macron
was
saying this you can only imagine the
kind of fear
about those sorts of numbers you know
you need such a such a huge um
such a huge breakthrough for a vaccine
uh program to work and and
they're terrifying figures really that
coming out of places like poland
yeah interesting seeing president macron
just in the last few moments
saying in coming days and weeks we will
have to take
new health restrictions clearly this
third wave
causing huge problems right across the
continent let's move on to the front of
the financial times
uh graham away from the eu and to
india uh india dealing a blow to global
covid fight by blocking
vaccine exports so this is all about
kovacs
isn't it those supplies to uh countries
um that are really struggling
yeah that's right and i mean this is is
a potentially
seismic story you know that india is by
a distance the world's biggest supplier
of vaccinations through the kovac scheme
and what's happened is that today
they've announced that they are banning
exports for a period to prioritize
their own vaccinations i mean india is
about to go through what is its second
wave by comparison
india is a novice at this uh as as
compared to us but
but absolutely they've seen what's
happening elsewhere it's very it's very
um reminiscent of what we've been
talking about in the eu
and uh what they're talking about is
haunting exports for up to two or three
months according to the uh it comes to
the ft
it's kind of a big impact here and this
is we're talking about a minimum of five
million doses in the uk alone and
obviously
you ally that to the to the pressures
that come in the eu and and
we're not talking about that again
interesting to see along similar lines
the world is scared of coronavirus it's
pushing the nature of a global
marketplace it linked to its limits the
eu
and india are super powers but um
they're not really in a position to look
like it now you know
india looks a little bit panicked and
you know what after what was seen here
that there might be right to be
yeah uh let's move on to the daily
telegraph yet another angle
on the vaccine story uh astrazeneca
attacks are unfair says uh professor
this is sir john
bell from the oxford university who
helped develop
the astrazeneca covid uh vaccine i mean
astrazeneca saying tonight that it
denies it's not honoring its contracts i
mean
clearly they are coming under uh quite a
lot of stick um uh
tell us what the professor's been saying
yeah that's right well well he's come
out and and reflected kind of what it
measures a wider
feeling at astrazeneca which is to say
you know but they're doing this
they're doing this not to uh to to um to
earn a profit
and uh and and they may well never do
this again um
and you can kind of understand that you
can understand why really it's been
uh you you talked before about about the
the reticent that still resistance that
still exists across
the european union despite um the the
the results of the tests and the fact
that
that um they've all kind of stood it up
what i think is interesting about
astrazeneca is
it's become a very uh tribal thing you
know that the um
that we were the uk yeah on the ice
astrazeneca team it almost feels like uh
like they could be playing in the in the
premier league sort of thing you know
everyone's got
absolute sympathy for these people you
know that they're they're saying that
they were doing it you know that
it's a vaccine that means that we can
finally get out that you can finally hug
your grandmother and blah blah blah
meanwhile
astrazeneca uh suffering a um
a pr nightmare from it just just doesn't
seem right and and uh
and he's certainly reflecting that
annoyance
okay now i'm hearing that uh carol is
with us now let's hope that we can see
carol
there she is hi carol you okay
no stressed well listen we know we know
somewhere you haven't been and that's in
the pub
um let's let's let's get cracking
straight away carol great to see you by
the way front page of the guardian
public check
strategy to make young people seek uh
vaccine i mean the pub story and the uh
the pub passport story's been around all
day today everyone
seems to have an opinion on it um carol
where do you stand
um you know i worry about our freedoms i
worry about the fact that we're gonna
have to have
some kind of certificate to go into
apartment maybe even a restaurant
i mean the story on on the front of the
guardian it's talking about
um you know compulsory uh entry into
pops may
may encourage younger people who
might be reticent to get the jab to to
get it so they can go into work
i think a lot of young people because
they know that the virus is not going to
harm them too much because it's not
going to
lay them low they're not worried about a
vaccine they're not worried about
getting it but
the problem is that they can spread it
so i think this idea
so what the guardian of running is
saying the government hopes that that
some kind of pastel might encourage a
lot of younger people and
some places like israel which has the
you know the most successful vaccine
rollout in the world
they're noticing an apathy in under 35
year olds
people who just aren't going to get the
vaccine because they
they too don't feel that that if they
get it it's going to do them too much
harm so
yeah i mean i can i can see i can see
the point
of of the vaccine passport but it
worries me that this sort of thing will
stay in place for a long time i don't
want to live in a country
where everywhere you go you have to have
some sort of certification maybe
for now maybe initially it's not a
terrible idea
but i don't want to see these sort of
things you know
become part of our culture become part
of our society
okay and carol just while we while we
have still got you we've been talking to
graham uh a lot about uh the headlines
regarding the eu
and uh the vaccine issues uh us live on
the line uh
speaking at a news conference uh this
evening talking about transparency
and talking about uh the eu getting what
is fair
for europeans um what are your thoughts
well you know you i mean i find it
astonishing that they're talking about
what's there
you know the eu city
[Music]
let's leave it there we're going to go
to a break i'm going to give you the
chance to catch your breath
uh reboot your computer and uh hopefully
we'll speak to you again
in a couple of minutes coming up
graham's colleagues report on the plight
of a ten-year-old boy
whose housing situation forced him into
an extreme
school commute talk about that in a
couple of minutes
so the first time was when i was 14 um
eight i was in i think i was in year
eight or nine in school
and um a young boy in my year was
pestering me for an image
and i was actually being bullied since i
was 11 since i got into the school
by the same group of people actually
notably i got bullied quite a lot by the
boys in my year
i guess i saw this as a bit of a gateway
to
maybe being accepted maybe if one of
these boys liked me
the bullying would stop that had almost
tainted my school experience from
from the age of 11. so um after he
pestered me for a few weeks i sent him
an image
and the following day it was
just completely viral in our community
um
every single person in my school had it
my school actually suspended me uh for
my
behavior um and you know said how
inappropriate it was
um which is obviously you know hugely
damaging to
you know a 14 year old girl who is now
actually seen as a victim back in
2011 or whatever it was um there was no
revenge pawn laws the way that there are
now and becoming more and more um
structured
and i was again a victim at 21 i was
actually in a relationship
and we broke up and he forwarded
some images onto his friends and then
when i went on to love island his
friends i think
i gather remembered that they had these
images of me
and circulated them to their friends and
so forth and they actually went
worldwide so
i've experienced it twice i feel like i
went through every single emotion
um at 14 if i'm honest i
there were there were days where i
thought i can't i don't want to be on
this earth anymore i don't see a way out
and
i don't see this getting better it was
back in those days i guess it wasn't
that long ago but 10 years ago it's such
an
unrecognized issue um and i felt every
emotion the embarrassment the shame
there's so much of a lack of
understanding around this topic
still um and i guess as well when i was
21 i think i felt more so the feelings
of anger you know
what gives someone else the rights over
my body
um and i and i feel that anger and
that's the anger that fueled me to
to make my documentary and to speak more
openly about this issue because it is
such a huge issue
[Music]
so
welcome back you're watching the press
preview have we got carol haven't we
let's find out
uh we have certainly got graham there he
is but we haven't got carol
poor old carol she's really struggling
with her internet connection
uh tonight graham let's start with your
story on the front of the birmingham
mail then your paper
pupil 10 in 85 mile trip to school
um uh tell us why
yeah absolutely well i should start by
sending finally we've got a northern and
a midland voice and a tv show and then
we don't manage to to actually uh to
hear but we'll get there eventually
um so yes this is a story about a very
determined little boy who just won't
give up
um so isaac is familiar from eritrea
where more than half of people live in
abject poverty
in eritrea in fact everyone in every
trail lives in poverty uh his family
have
found themselves amongst thousands of
people living in tempe accommodation in
birmingham which means
in effect for them being passed from one
hotel to another to another
indeed young guys except at more than
eight temporary homes over
over his time and but eventually he
ended up living in manchester due to a
shortage in birmingham
now this isn't well this is a council
knocking story but that isn't why it's
on our front page really for me
this is a story about a brilliant little
boy and also a brilliant brilliant
parents
they get up at five o'clock every day
and have a 170
mile round trip back to his school in
hansworth in birmingham
this case is what it is is it's evidence
of a broken welfare housing system that
in birmingham that leaves thousands of
kids in this city trapped in hotels and
flats
and and local campaigners going to
demand in some things
will happen should happen about it we've
got six thousand kids that are in
temporary accommodation in birmingham
um and you know he gets gets suggested
to us this is kind of uniquely a
asylum seeker but it isn't it isn't at
all um the answer is more affordable
housing but the reason again this story
is in the front page
is that um it just says to us we aren't
inherently better than asylum seekers in
in a week where we've seen home
secretary
pritchett patel say we want to work
harder to
make it harder for asylum seekers to
come in particularly when it's deemed
that they offer little to our economy
here we're talking about people who've
escaped the worst kind of poverty
and i mean i don't know what isaac's
parents will contribute to the to the
country but what i would say is it's
pretty amazing that they're driving this
um yeah an important story to uh
to highlight um hi carol nice to see you
again
i'm sorry i'm sorry you're struggling
tonight listen hopefully um hopefully
you know what it's it's astonishing this
is graham's first
time doing this and he's doing it on his
own
it's a baptism of fire straight in the
deep end carol
he's done very well he's done very well
uh but we're pleased to see you again
listen we haven't got too long but i do
want to squeeze this story in carroll if
i can on the front of the daily
telegraph it's a story that
our college tom palminter has done for
us this evening um
this is all about uh the uh the teacher
who showed
a cartoon of the prophet muhammed to his
class and there's been a
huge outcry where do you stand on this
well it's you know the ganon willis
williamson the educational secretary
tonight has said you know that what's
been happening outside the school today
is totally unacceptable there's been
chaos there's been lots of parents out
there
lots of protests out there this teacher
has been suspended but more important
this teacher has had to go into hiding
because there have been threats on his
life
this is just not what should be
happening in this country
you know we can't have teachers going
into hiding because they're doing their
job
on the curriculum for for um for this
school
it said the syllabus is for calderdale
kirklis and lee's
says pupils are supposed to be able to
give reasons
why representations of god and the
prophets are forbidden
so presumably this teacher was just
following the syllabus
i don't know it's not written whether
whether pictures of muhammad
the prophet muhammad should be shown but
it we can't have
this is a secular country we can't have
a situation where
teachers are in fear of their lives
because they're following the school's
syllabus um you know i think was sajid
javid today he said
you know in this country we are free to
to peacefully follow
preach or query any religion or
non and that's got to be right uh yeah
the teacher offered a sincere and full
apology adding that the picture
uh shown was completely inappropriate
graham you've just got about uh
10 seconds to give us your thoughts yeah
and it's it's hard to
to disagree with carolina fundamentally
when you took you're teaching about
religion the idea is that you go
alongside tolerance
and i mean i understand that that this
is an insult in in this religion
but fundamentally tolerance goes both
ways and this is an evidence is an
example of that okay
um graeme uh well done you uh uh baptism
at five but you're excellent thank you
carol great to see you and we'll speak
to you both again in half an hour
[Music]
for the early risers as we examine the
story beyond the headline
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news's entertainment
[Applause]
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free
[Music]
you